j'ai beaucoup pensé à toi récemment je
passais dans le coin alors je me suis
dit que j'allais dire bonjour à mon ami
serge savard yade à voir avec le métier
j'espère un peu quand même si j'ai plus
envie de jouer c'est fini ça fait des
années je suis pas monté sur les
planches alors je te le dise le nom de
la pièce j'ai pas envie de connaître le
nom de cette pièce le misanthrope parce
que je te propose pile je fais alceste
fasse ses doigts qui s il faut par
hasard qu'un ami votre avis que pour
avoir vos biens on dresse un artifice
coach
excuse-moi dérive où tout cela sans vous
mettre en cours ou et s'il faut par
hasard qu'un ami vous trahissent que moi
[ __ ] mais c'est infernal ton truc
portable sur molière maintenant vous
savez ma nièce où il abat votre actrice
fait que l'invocation c'est qu'elle veut
faire sacristain fixe elle m'a dit
textuellement une double peiné à 8
heures du matin
c'est pas évident excusez moi mais vous
savez que gauthier à un acteur très
connu en ce que je vous dise que j'ai
lues par les lecteurs
jugé trop des narcisses qu'est-ce qu'il
vous dit que les îles un peu réseau 3-13
mars il faut fléchir autant sans
obstination et c'est une assez du tout
va alors ses obstinations px1 prépare à
sion masturbation au tout ce que tu peux
tu me laisses tire le texte comme
j'entends moins autant jouer du
classique on respecte les veille
quand on partait de bon matin quand on
partait sur les chemins à bicyclette et
s'avoue ravi d'avoir blessé un peu on
était tout cela fait cinq jours que tu
joues avec moi mais maintenant c'est
terminé
tu n'as aucune intention de jouer ce
spectacle la seule chose qui m'intéresse
c'est le petit pouvoir que tu as sur les
gens